We can understand the importance
of authentication by going back
to the discussion we had about what
a trusted computing base does.
So we have resources that need
to be protected and we can do
that by having a trusted computing
base that is a reference monitor.
Every request that comes for
a resource has to be monitored.
And when you monitor the request,
the question you have is,
should this request be able
to access the resource for
which that is the target
of this request?
To answer that question we
really have to establish
who is the request coming from.
The source of the request is,
we're going to be able to identify that
because we have
authentication in the system.
So let's look a little bit more closely
at what authentication really is.
Authentication, we said we have to
establish the source of the request.
So we have to ask the question, who
are you, if you happen to be the source?
And of course,
you can't just claim to be anybody.
When you're going to claim that
you are Alice, you have to provide
some evidence to us that is going to
convince us that you really are Alice.
So authentication is knowing the
identity of the source and establishing
that it indeed is that person who is
making that claim about the identity.
So once we establish the source of
a request, convince ourselves that
the user is who he or she claims to be,
the next part is authorization.
So in authorization we're
really establishing
whether the source of the request does
have the permissions necessary for
the resource that they want to access.
So this permission check is
the authorization process and
once authentication and
authorization is done,
of course then we allow access to
the resource when permitted and
the source of the request is able
to make use of the resources.
So let's dig a little bit deeper
into this question about what is
authentication?
We just discussed that
the operating system or
the trusted computing base,
OS is that plus more perhaps.
So the OS of the trusted
computing base needs to know
who is making a request for
the resource that is protected.
So access to that resource
has to be secured.
So we know that in a computer system
a request actually comes from a process.
This process may be running one of your
services, your browser, a mail client,
whatever it is.
So processes making the request, but
we know that processes
are run on behalf of users.
So a given process that is
making a request must be running
on behalf on a certain user.
We call the user also a subject or
a principal.
These are the active entities
that actually initiate request or
cause actions.
So these terms are used interchangeably,
but we'll stick with user.
So process runs on behalf of a user.
Authentication, which is our topic,
essentially is going to help us
answer this question that we have,
is that if a process is making a request
to know who's making the request,
what user is making the request,
we must answer the question on whose
behalf is the process running?
So the requesting process makes
the request by making a system call.
It comes through the operating system,
but
on whose behalf is it making that call?
To establish the user on whose
behalf the process is running,
of course we have to start
with authentication.
In the beginning,
when a user comes to the system,
the user is going to
authenticate himself or herself.
So that's how we, for example,
start a login session.
You login to the system, or start the
session that's going to launch one or
more processes that you need to run, and
then in the end the session
is going to be over.
So when you start the login session,
prior to launching the process
that is making the request,
of course you're going to make
a claim about your identity.
You're going to tell the system, I am
Alice, and then the system is going to
ask you, well give me some evidence so
I can believe that you really are Alice.
And when that evidence is
provided we need to verify it.
The verification actually tells us that
the user is actually who he or she
claims to be, and then that user launch
an application or start a process.
And that process is then going to have,
sometimes we say credentials of this
user, because this
user was authenticated.
In other words, those processes
are going to run on behalf
of that user that just authenticated,
and
whatever resources this user is
able access, those processes
will be able to successfully
gain access to those resources.
So really, requests when we talk about,
do come from processes, but
processes run on behalf of users.
And the system knows what user
a process is running on behalf of
because of authentication,
because that comes before the process
gets launched and makes the request.